khalid abdullah is a victim of syria's
war
more than 13 million people that's half
the population before the war are in a
similar situation either forced to flee
the country or are displaced within its
borders
anymore i am 70 years old
i prefer to die than live like this
in poverty in misery and without my
children who are now scattered
everywhere
for most life in exile is becoming more
permanent in the opposition controlled
north hundreds of thousands of syrians
are being moved out of tents into
concrete housing units
it's some relief from the cold winters
and hot summers but it's not home
opponents of the government civilians
and fighters men women and children were
forced to move when government troops
gradually recaptured territory over the
years of fighting
it's not easy leaving home it's painful
there is a lot of pain
we hope to return one day and live under
a new system of government
eleven years on front lines still divide
the country and the regime and the
opposition are far from a political
solution
a new generation has only known war and
life in camps for many of the displaced
returning to president bashar al-assad
syria is not an option in the absence of
safety guarantees political reform and
justice
five years ago we left our homes our
livelihoods my husband was killed in
lota they threw us here and there's
nothing for us
time has done little to erase memories
of a violent conflict which is now in a
stalemate
they forced us from our homes after
heavy bombardment they destroyed street
by street
they dropped barrel bombs on us and
killed so many people who were besieged
and hungry
serious displacement crisis has been
described as this century's largest
human exodus many have been forced to
find safety many times over but their
troubles are being compounded by a
collapsing economy
it's a stark reality across the war-torn
nation where sixty percent of the
population are facing hunger zener al
jazeera